okay so let's let's just put it on the
table here okay et is frequently cited
as one of the worst video games in
history i got to read a magazine that
said that my game was single-handedly
responsible for the crash of the video
game industry in the early 80s
that's a good one people are reticent to
ask me about it they think i'm very
sensitive about it you know oh my god
you did the worst game of all time you
know don't you want to hide and it's
like
no howard scott warsha he was a video
game programmer for atari in the early
80s he made some of the most beloved
games for the atari 2600 i made yar's
revenge then i followed that with
raiders of the lost ark i had had two uh
very successful games both million
sellers i truly believed that everything
i touched hopefully was going to turn to
gold because i was going to put
everything i had into it one fateful day
howard received a call from the ceo of
atari asking him if he wanted to take on
their highest profile game ever e.t the
extraterrestrial and i said we
definitely can do that but there was one
major caveat it had to be something that
related to the movie and it had to be
doable in five weeks
i mean i had five weeks to do the game
so i was working all the time
et was going to be a basic puzzle game
with some challenges that you run around
to solve and if i redistribute the
pieces among enough different random
places it makes a fresh challenge each
time around and bingo
when it was released et was an immediate
success selling over a million copies
but a few months later things started to
turn
retailers are starting to find that the
game is not moving it's coming back a
lot of people are disappointed with it
because of the poor planning and type
production schedule howard failed to
catch a fundamental flaw in the game's
design there are too many times where
you make a move you do something and
suddenly you wind up somewhere else now
suddenly or somewhere else and there's
too many places in et where the user is
disoriented and that's a sin of which i
am guilty and i have been serving
penance
shortly after et's release the video
game crash was in full swing
disappointing sales and mismanagement
forced atari to restructure and in the
next couple of months atari went from 10
000 employees to 2 000 employees during
the turmoil howard left the gaming
industry for good he didn't think much
about et until nearly a decade later
well by the early 90s people started
coming out with what a bad game et was i
was just kind of surprised anybody was
actually even talking about it good
afternoon some of those 18 atari games
unearthed at a new mexico landfill are
now up for sale beaten up cartridges on
ebay are going for hundreds of dollars
apiece
[Applause]
where fans could choose what game they
wanted to see you play okay they chose
this
e.t the extraterrestrial
even 30 years later this obscure thing
that i did so long ago in just five
weeks it's still generating excitement
enthusiasm i get emotional just talking
about it now because i just thought i
was at the center of something that is
still meaningful and that is a huge
success so when people ask me you know
was et a failure
i don't mind when people call it that
but it'll never it'll never be a failure
to make
[Music]
you